in the interest of efficiency will be
responding rapid fire style to Tick-Tock
videos attacking me just over the past
two weeks or so I say this will be rapid
fire but take that with a grain of salt
I'm not Ben Shapiro so rapid fire is
relative eventually we actually hit
chipmunk speed and then we go silent and
we go back in time anyway let's go
through these Matt Walsh is a fascist
who is promoting violence against trans
people his language is inflammatory and
factually incorrect that is
such
the idea that being trans is the result
of some kind of social contagion has
been disproven so many times the theory
of Rapid onset gender dysphoria comes
from a survey of 256 parents of trans
children and not from the trans children
themselves article has been removed and
criticized for bad methodology after
being peer-reviewed it was found that
rabid onset genders for it isn't even a
formal medical diagnosis it was found
that between 2017 and 2019 the rates of
teenagers identifying as trans didn't
even increase theory of Rapid onset
gender dysphoria argues that trans
children identify as trans because
they're trying to escape social stigma
or to become more popular with their
peer group this makes no sense because
rates of bullying and suicidality
amongst trans youth is consistently
higher when compared to their CIS peers
the idea that the existence of trans
influences like Dylan Mulvaney are
somehow transiting your kids is
completely unfounded none of Dylan's
content that I have ever seen argues
that you should be trans or is trying to
promote transness onto children at all
but where to begin you say that the
survey about rapid onset gender
dysphoria was invalid because they
interviewed parents rather than the
children themselves well
yes if a child is sucked into a social
contagion he's not going to report that
he's been sucked into a social contagion
are you actually trying to prove that
children aren't being indoctrinated by
arguing that the indoctrinated children
say they haven't been indoctrinated yes
I mean if you go to your local
Scientology Center and you ask anyone
there whether they've been brainwashed
they're all going to say no you're
stepping over a line now you're stepping
over line you know you are if you don't
like the term rapid onset gender
dysphoria you can call it whatever you
want if you prefer something less
clinical sounding then just call it uh
wow look at all of these kids calling
themselves trans all of a sudden
syndrome
point is that according to data compiled
by The Williams Institute only half a
percent of all adults in this country
identify as trans while the number for
kids between the ages of 13 and 17 is
1.4 that's nearly three times higher and
the numbers are even more striking when
you break them down by generation
there's a Gallup poll that found that
there are twice as many trans
identifiers in gen Z as there are among
Millennials and there are many more
among Millennials and among Baby Boomers
for Baby Boomers it's uh 0.2 percent
identify as trans for Gen Z it's nearly
two percent point two percent versus two
percent that is a 10 X increase
do you think this happened by accident
or perhaps you would say that there have
always been this many trans people in
the world but they weren't free to live
their truth or whatever well the trouble
with that theory is that there's
absolutely not even one single shred of
evidence to support the dramatic claim
that there have always been Millions
upon millions of closeted trans people
through history
now you can either believe what the data
tells you what all of it tells you all
of it
or you can invent a story entirely
unsupported completely built on your
imagination about millions and millions
and millions of theoretical trans people
in older Generations who don't show up
in the data this is what you're reduced
to have you ever read the fine print
that appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school your internet
service provider but actually stop
people from monitoring your online
activity you need to do what I do and
use expressvpn think about all the times
you use Wi-Fi at a coffee shop hotel or
even a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network that's still
true even when you're in incognito mode
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it to
a network of secure servers so your
private online activity stays private
expressvpn is super easy to use the app
has one button you tap it to connect and
your browsing activity is secure it's as
simple as that stop letting strangers
invade your online privacy protect
yourself at expressvpn.com walshyt use
my Link at expressvpn.com walshyt to get
three extra months free that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh YT you cannot be
something and also the negation of that
thing at the same time Matt Walsh is
just going to be upset with people using
Mac or labels what the is this see
he wants to have it both ways where he
hates the oversaturation of language of
microlabels yet when something is not
100 consistent and precise enough he
gets mad at that too art sniffing mumbo
jumbo now he's taking issue with micro
labeling despite earlier
complaining that macro labeling is not
specific enough you can't have it both
ways you have to use umbrella terms
which are not going to be exactly
precise yet as long as we understand
that if somebody says bisexual and
asexual they're probably referring to
romantic attraction to both genders well
thank you for reminding me about my fart
sniffing mumbo jumbo line I'm quite
proud of that now my issue uh is not
with the act of labeling there is some
amount of labeling that's necessary and
normal human beings label things so they
can communicate coherently with each
other about those things but coherence
is the point here when the labels create
incoherence then they defeat the purpose
of the entire exercise that's so I can't
stop me because I can read if the label
doesn't clarify but rather creates more
confusion then it's not even a label
it's more of an anti-label it's an
attempt to make it harder for people to
understand what something is not easier
calling yourself a bisexual asexual is
exactly like calling yourself a meat
eating vegan it tastes just like KFC I
know now you say that perhaps asexuals
experience a little sexual attraction to
both sexes and that somehow justifies
calling a bisexual asexual but that's
like saying that a meat eating vegan is
a vegan who eats only a little bit of
meat it's just a hamburger not all the
time you're disgusting well by
definition if you eat a little bit of
meat then you eat meat which means you
aren't a vegan you may be a less
enthusiastic meat eater or a reluctant
meat eater or an occasional meat eater
or maybe there's some other adjective
you can affix there but a vegan is
someone who doesn't eat meat period an
asexual experiences no sexual attraction
If you experience sexual attraction
you're not asexual that's just like your
opinion man see this is the other
problem with your compulsive and
incoherent labeling you don't allow for
variations within the labels you pretend
that you do you pretend that you're all
about variation you embrace all kinds of
variety you claim but you don't because
the moment you notice a variation Within
in a category you create a whole new
category for that variation and you do
this kind of thing everywhere in every
context the most obvious example of
course is how you've eliminated
masculine women from existence tomboys
we used to call them you've erased that
variation by labeling them trans men
this is the worst part about the way
that you label it's not just that it's
incoherent it's also that it's so damned
limiting
why on Earth did you hit that woman
right let me show you baby
that ain't no woman it's a man man
[Music]
[Applause]